what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today
um I am reacting to a video that is the
introduction to mgtow and it was a a
channel that I haven't I might have
watched it like a long time ago but I
don't really remember I think it's
called Sandman is that it I think it's
Sandman so uh let's I think someone
recommended this to me on Instagram
which you should
um DM me if you want me to react uh just
pearly things one hi everyone Sandman
here oh and for those of you that don't
know mgtows men going their own way so
basically they don't deal with women
um until the laws change as far as I
understand I'm getting a number of
people asking me to do an introduction
video for mgtow so here it is I'm going
to cover 25 of the most important video
topics that I've covered since I've
started my channel and the first thing
to remember about mgtow is that a man
that has taken the metaphorical red pill
is a man that has learned the ugly truth
about female nature women are made out
to be harmless Beautiful Creatures but
the truth is many women hey beautiful
creature here and that has taken the
metaphorical red pill is a man that has
learned the ugly truth about female
nature women are made out to be harmless
Beautiful Creatures but the truth is
many women today will rip out your heart
and testicles through your wallet and
move on to their next victim that's true
though the more the more I learn about
the court system I can't even I can't
even fault you with absolutely no second
thoughts and they often have no guilt or
remorse in the process so taking the red
pill is making yourself aware of how
women operate and you stop being naive
about it with regards to becoming a
mgtow there are four or five different
levels to make Tau the first level is
the purple pill man this is the man
that's aware that women use the
government the courts and men's desires
to reproduce to take advantage of men
but the purple pill man believes that
the risks of a relationship in marriage
are often worth the potential punishment
a level 2 mgtow believes I'm really glad
he's breaking this down for me this is
very helpful okay so purple pill is
because I've heard purple pill and I
really didn't understand what it meant
so it basically means they're aware of
how women are but I'm still gonna deal
with these because I want a family
dating in short-term relationships but
not marriage long-term relationships or
cohabitation with women okay so level
two is I'll date the girls I'll screw
them but that's it no marriage no kids
to him these often seem very dangerous a
level 3 mgtow doesn't believe in dating
women at all and limits his interactions
with women as much as possible a level 4
mgtow tries to limit his interactions
with the state and everyone else as much
as possible too three limits his
reactions and I understand why
um level three would limit their
interactions with women because they
also could get
um like a false allegation like that's I
think their primary concern and the
fourth one they don't want to talk to
anyone at all he is what is referred to
as a guy that's ghosting or trying to
stay invisible to women and the state
all of this is explained okay so to
women the state in Greater detail in a
video marked number one below in the
description called mgtow dating so once
you know where you stand with regards to
the Spectrum then you either have a
choice to stay away from women entirely
or take varying relationship risks then
you basically can start to gain true
situational awareness this is where you
start to identify different types of
female behavior and begin to understand
what motivates women to act in such ways
one very important thing to remember is
that many more women today in their 20s
than in past Generations are riding the
Carousel this means they are having
no strings attached sex with in some
cases dozens of men before they decide
to settle down with a single guy dozens
Jesus Christ if they decide to settle
down at all I'm linking to my video
called the Carousel which is number
two down below I'm surprised you can say
this on YouTube are you surprised
like
black yeah from now on each and every
topic that I bring up I will put a link
to it below and at this point I'm going
to stop mentioning it and let you
explore these particular topics on your
own and explore the description behind
your own as well women look to settle
down with a beta male provider a blue
pill man with little to no understanding
about female nature if he's ignorant
about the way women operate then he's
more easily manipulated a man aware of
how women function in society and
manipulate men in covert ways are harder
to guilt and shame into doing the things
that she wants he knows the game so he's
harder to trick into marriage protection
and resource extraction shame is the
name of many women's game and in this
case it doesn't work after a woman
convinces her beta male blue pill man
that marriage is a good idea for him
then she has a child or two which at
some point allow her to leave that
relationship and use those children as a
way to get child support from her
husband people wonder why men go their
own way and one of the biggest reasons
is that they have been burned by women
through the divorce courts and are often
paying lifetime alimony as well as child
support to their ex-wives in many cases
the family courts also award the full
value of the family home to wives and
the majority of men visiting this
YouTube channel are often in their 30s
40s and 50s men that have been taken to
the cleaners so to speak and have had
their eyes opened a little too late they
are here to become mgtows because they
are shocked at the way women took
advantage of them as well they're here
to understand how women use their beauty
and behavior to trick men another
important thing to remember is that
women age like milk while men age like
wine and I'm putting a link to a video
called women in the wall down below many
women's looks for those who that don't
know the wall is like when we hit I
don't know I've heard different ages for
the wall the earliest stage I've heard
is 26. the latest age I've heard is 30.
you know I have had guys say up to 35
but I think those guys are like calf and
a little like we know it's basically
when your looks like fade is the best
way to to say it it's like it doesn't
mean that your looks are gone but the
way that I understand it it's like at 18
you look one way and at 28 you realize
you don't look the same way you did at
18 and your options are significantly
less or you could do 20 and 30 if you
think 18 is weird ability to attract a
wealthy attractive mate decline rapidly
as they hit the age of 30. men's
attractiveness often increases with age
because they tend to make more money as
they age and often have larger bank
accounts and savings while generally
women's earnings potential Withers with
their looks especially if they've had
children the age of 30 is roughly where
male and female values intersect and
then go that's so interesting because oh
that's so true because they say that men
are women out or men under the age of 30
in major cities but I guess the idea is
that some of that comes from the money
they make off of their beauty I'm
guessing anyway the opposite direction
if a man doesn't get married by the age
of 35 or 40 then there's only roughly a
12 chance that he's going to get married
from that point forward wait wow the guy
hasn't gotten married by the time he's
35 or 40 there's a 12 chance he'll get
married another reason men should go
their own way is because of tests women
often test men's ability to be providers
and tolerate their horrible Behavior the
idea is to turn a man into an obedient
broken shell of his former self that
walks around saying yes dear all of the
time his Spirit has to be broken in many
cases so his resources become more
easily extracted and he is more
malleable he becomes silly putty in her
hands a woman asking a man to do
something over the top is not her being
loving or showing love but instead she's
testing him to see if he can be
manipulated in the Iran huh so if a girl
says that I need you to do something
over the top she's trying to see how
well that she can control it you know
what I don't think I've ever asked for
anything over the top like crazy I think
everything over the top that's happened
like that I've been given like he just
gave it to me like I never asked but I'm
thinking about it and I'm thinking about
those guys that do the rose petals and
do like the full like Valentine's Day
stuff and they always are a little bit
simpy thing is that women want to
manipulate men but when the manipulation
and works they tend to lose interest
with regards to love there are often
questions as to so we're always trying
to manipulate men and if it doesn't work
we lose women are even capable of loving
men the way that men love women men
scale mountains because they love women
they cross Seas invent things write
poetry and revolutionize the world it's
my own opinion as well as the opinion of
many other mgtows that women are not
hardwired for the same level of love
that men are this is partially to do
with the fact that women need to look
after children and need to divert those
resources elsewhere anyways mgtow men
want North America and Europe to turn
into Japan we want men refusing to
provide love and resources to women on a
civilization-wide scale until Society
crumbles women are selfish yeah okay is
that what's happening in Japan I know
I've seen that like single women that's
that's really bad in Japan ultiman up
and take responsibility and we don't
want to take responsibility for
childlike women that have given up on
their own responsibilities but continue
to demand that we men provide them
entitlements because they have a golden
vagina when a man tries to live for
himself women he's kind of funny is dude
but a midlife crisis and try to shame
him back into submission yet when a
woman goes through menopause men are
supposed to just tolerate her hot
flashes as well as mood swings but a man
in a midlife crisis needs therapy
according to women oh that's so true
that's so true they never send women in
menopause to therapy but they always
talk about how men that are in midlife
crisis is the guy we mgtows look up to
the most is Nikola Tesla a lifelong
bachelor that invented many of the
technologies that we use today he
registered hundreds of patents and
invented the 20th century by many
accounts do you think that he could have
invented all the things that he did if
he had a wife and children to support
most mgtows also avoid long-term
relationships because women have
multiple male friends that they use for
different functions effectively women
have the equivalent of a male harem one
man to sleep away hold on with one to
bankroll her another one to use is an
emotional tampon okay one man to sleep
with one to pay for everything and one
to use as an emotional tampon what else
and other men for all kinds of functions
One Man simply can't satisfy the Modern
Woman and the sooner men realize this
the sooner they can go their own way a
traditional marriage and family is a
great male friends are really common
nowadays I mean I don't know girls with
straight up like sugar daddies or
anything I I said well well I should say
well it's not uncommon okay okay for men
in this day and age if a man wants a
child of his own I would suggest that he
go to either Mexico or Thailand and have
a surrogate mother give birth to his own
child that way his child can never be
taken away by the mother that's true
that is true that's the only that's the
one thing the more I'm learning about
the court system the more I realize when
men have kids those kids aren't theirs
anyway it's the moms because if she
doesn't want them to see it see the kid
there ain't really you can do about
it
um and that's what I talked to a girl
the other day that was like oh well why
doesn't he just keep fighting for his
kid and I used to think like that too oh
my gosh I totally did I was like why
wouldn't you go to court like it didn't
make any sense to me like if you're a
good dad you go to court until I
realized how bad the court system is I
really it's not really known to people
honestly in day-to-day life and so then
he looks like a deadbeat but the more
honestly the more I learn about the
court system the more I think that
deadbeat dads are a myth and that and I
I don't know this is just me thinking
out loud but I think that deadbeat dads
are a myth because I think that it's
it's not the men not wanting to be a
part of their kids lives it's more the
women not letting the dads be a part of
their lives more so than men not wanting
to and he often pays 30 to 40 000 to
have his own child free and clear that
he can raise in any which way he wants
what's also really unfortunate today is
that many men get married and now that
they're married just now do they realize
they've gotten married and have kids and
are effectively mgtows they see the
benefit to it but they're stuck in the
relationship this issue of being a
closeted mgtow is one that many of my
listeners face other men get married
because they like to play a game called
Captain Save A Hoe they want to rescue
him
oh that's funny okay by paying off their
student loans buying them a nice home
and Furnishing it as well as spoiling
them rotten like princesses yet many of
the women they tend to rescue are used
up that have been riding the
carousel for most of their lives he's
kind of funny isn't he
for her to date bad boys and jerks
instead of good loving supportive and
good-hearted men many men can't even get
dates or relationships these days
because they seem to be unattractive to
women and women have no interest in
dating them and having sex with them but
it's much harder for unattractive men
than it is for unattractive women and
men that are incapable of getting dates
and getting into relationships are often
called tfellers or true Force loneliness
type of guys many of them are bitter
because they cannot get female attention
and many of them focus on conspiracies
theories instead as a hobby some men go
overseas and look for foreign Brides to
marry and this too is a bad idea because
female nature is the same everywhere
around the world bringing a foreign
bride back to a Western Country ensures
that in many cases that she will leave
you many times foreign women are
marrying foreign men just to get a new
passport and once they enter this new
country they find more attractive males
if she left the country of her own
origin behind what makes you think that
she won't leave you behind is that was
that a good point wait that was kind of
of a good boy I mean most of the time
passport Bros leave their wives no I've
seen a couple that brought him back if
she'll leave her country but I never
thought about it that way that's kind of
a good point that's kind of a good point
another possible solution for men
looking for love are synthetic lovers in
Japan people pay for affection
conversation sex and often each of their
needs are met in a service type of
setting but some men are not content
doing this and she used to search for
nawalt nawalt stands for not all women
are like that and apparently there's
okay okay I swear I swear I used to I
feel like I've probably said that at
some point but it's the most annoying
complaint to me well not all women but
okay and I was looking at the virginity
rates from a hundred years ago like what
percent of women admitted to having
premarital sex
um and it was only like I think 15 it
was it was less than 30 because I think
I said it was 15 let's say women lie
right women live so let's double it
let's say we're gonna double it 30
percent that means two out of three
women I mean slightly more or virgins of
their wedding night so you could say
well not all women are like that not all
women have only fan and that's true but
but it's like you're taking away from
the point which is to be honest ladies
we don't really bring a lot to the table
nowadays just as a group like you can
you can say well I'm the best player on
my team but you're still on the losing
team you're still on the team that's
bringing down Society a number of women
that are not into marrying men for their
money and resources as their primary
motivator but they genuinely care about
men such a woman is rare and often like
a purple squirrel or a unicorn but
sometimes a man that goes after women
constantly gets friend zoned the friend
zone is a place where man becomes a
utility for a woman but gains no sexual
favors Pleasures or a relationship in
return for the friendship that he
provides a woman and even if he does
marry her she will Tire of him almost
certainly in her 30s and she will say
things like not tonight honey and deny
him sexual release and pass simply use
that as a way to control him but the
truth of the matter is that what is
happening today has ultimately been
caused by men's Ingenuity without the
oil to run our economy women would not
have all of the benefits of cheap food
and tons of Leisure Time men have
released the oil Genie out of the bottle
and some male functions have become
obsolete because of it women are also
using new Communications Technologies
like smartphones and computers to
increase their pool of available men so
in turn they're getting that's smart
because so he's basically saying that
men created the society and invented all
this stuff for women to have a better
life and basically okay hear about the
types of men that they date modern
technology means that women can keep
searching for a better man even when
they have one at home it's just good
enough for now and I want to close this
video by talking about the true nature
of women women cower and hide under
their beds in a real emergency and last
Christmas the power in my city went out
for a few days due to a giant ice storm
and most of the women were inside of
their homes or at the shopping mall
while the men were out in the cold
working to restore power without men
civilization would collapse yet somehow
women think that they no longer need men
and that men are obsolete that is true
that that is so true when I hate women's
empowerment I hate it it's a stupid if
you want to go okay let's let's talk
real women's empowerment go be an
electrician that's that's empowering oh
no I don't
know what position because I've watched
all these movies and these girls have
these boss babe and it's just so Diana
but but that's true men have built up
Society for women to on them as a
thank you in a way well that does it for
my introduction to mgtow I've added
about 25 videos in the description below
that's so interesting he was kind of
making points wasn't he a little bit the
passport Bros thing if she'll leave her
country what makes her think makes you
think that she wouldn't leave you let me
know what you guys think in the comments
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time